I'm just two blocks from the Apollo
Theater and behind me is one of the
great institutions here in Harlem
Sylvia's restaurant they've been making
in serving soul food here since 1962
Sylvia woods family still runs the place
they've agreed to let me serve soul food
today in the restaurant what could go
wrong what could go wrong
this is one of Sylvia's granddaughters
is that right yes and your name is
the characters Akira let people call you
okay this is gonna shock you I don't
know much about soul food main
ingredient when you're dealing with soul
food is love oh we had none of that
growing up no there was no love in the
house and let alone enough left over to
put it in the food everyone's in it
Sophia everybody not everybody
there's Liza Minnelli yeah okay
is that Denzel right there that is okay
there's ice tea yep
look at him he looks so bad all the time
after you've just told him a really
funny joke
Bill Clinton everyone's having fun in
this picture no joy in his life Liza
Minnelli again
she keeps these in her purse she orders
a bunch of soup you're off getting it
look at this Liza Minnelli
yeah it's three times for Liza Minnelli
[ __ ] my photo up here would that be
hard to do no not at all but here's the
problem this is the face I'm making my
photo check it out that's
see I'm ready to get started how do I
begin
BAM boom okay be honest with me how does
the hair just look it's not it's not
cute I like white girls
I'm a dude
love you too I'm a very pretty white
girl over the counter
wouldn't that be faster good actually
the way you're doing it there we go here
you go
aspiring a little bit wipe down the
point on the first this is the best
chicken I've ever had and you know what
I love about it it's free who's paying
for it all right
hello the snow is in operation since
1962 Harlow these premiere soul food
restaurant tests soul food in Harlem
best place to get it only two blocks
from the Apollo Theater Malcolm X
Boulevard you got to come to Soviet they
hung up and you can find in what number
was that I don't know how to do that
this is like a nuclear launch code why
is this have to go through the Pentagon
I will try to use this system but I just
took money out of your ATM by the way
this is one of our cameraman James
during the ten minutes Conan was
learning the system James was trapped
near the register to avoid getting any
shots he was what he filmed for ten
minutes
[Music]
would you like would you like some
waffles would you like some biscuits
would you like chicken you want dark
meat white Pete you want it smother to
fry listen I get off work probably in 10
minutes I think I'm getting fired
well Sylvia's yep 1962 best soul food in
Harlem yep
come and see three count em three
photographs of liza minnelli for no
reason good to see you
Jesse Jesse good to see you you're a
Yankee fan red sox what are you talking
about listen you're in my restaurant
okay I've been working in Sylvia's for
45 minutes you can't come in here and
tell me that my team sucks one question
for you it's always Yankee Giants you
are Yankee Jets you know what I think
Giants suck this year and you switch to
that team
Giants jersey at home you buried it in
the backyard and you learned a chick's
Jersey so I'm giving away cakes today
that's for you man you're trying to kill
me just take it give it to someone on
the street so is yes free cakes today
[Applause]
[Applause]
I know I thought that I did a pretty
good job today and that I got better as
time went on I made some mistakes early
on is there someplace here I could work
well I'm not working the counter but I'm
still working at Sylvia's
and that's pretty cool soviets clean
dishes since 1962
[Music]
you
you